foreign
Winchester what's up Eric
how you doing Dr John party any money
what are you up to
oh not much just taking my break at work
there you go
what's up man how can I help
I just want to say before we start I
want to say thank you because over the
last few months you've really been a a
big factor in my personal development
and I appreciate you taking my call
today well I'm grateful for you
listening man and um never forget I'm
just a clown on a podcast or on YouTube
man you're the one actually having to
make hard choices every day so Props to
you brother it's awesome
so what's happening
I got one that's pretty big today and um
it's something I've kind of been stuck
on but I really need some some advice
all right hey do me a favor talk
directly into your phone okay
can you hear me now sir perfect that's
awesome fantastic
so um over the course of my life my uh
my father has not been the best husband
to my mother he is constantly you know
been
I'd say disrespectful towards her and
he's always had extra marital things
going on
um and it's kind of as I've gotten older
and I've had a son there are things that
he's done that I've vowed to never do
and they've kind of become part of a
moral code for me like
cheating lying those are two really big
things for me that are absolute no guys
um so my question is today is that uh
I'm not a Crossroads where I'm trying to
figure out if I should remove my father
from my life
because of the way he treats my mother
or if I should stay out of her marriage
problems
um I think there's a third option
I think that you were if you weaponize
your son
as a way to intervene in their marriage
that's a no-go
okay that's a way to get your kid burned
that's a way to get to it's just a way
to get your mom in more mess
um if you choose
to only have men of character in your
son's life
then you can look at your dad and he has
opted out of your son's life because of
the way he's chosen to live
and so that's a different proposition if
you
this would be a very difficult
conversation to have but if you sat down
and looked across the table and said Dad
um and by the way I would use very
specific language not you know you've
had some extramarital thing you've
cheated on my mom
and I will never know what was going on
behind closed doors I don't know how she
treated you behind closed I mean I don't
know any of that stuff I know you
cheated on my mom over and over and over
again I know you don't tell the truth
all the time and I'm committed to having
only men in my son's life who are men of
character
and now the choice is on you you could
have that call that conversation with
your old man it would be a powerful
conversation it probably will not go
well
um
but man it would be one where you would
walk real tall
and if you just especially if you did it
in a respectful dignified way not on the
back end of a fight like oh yeah y'all
are for Bush tall boys into a fight and
you're like oh you I tell you don't do
it like that but if you went down and
had a man-to-man conversation it could
be pretty incredible
but if you
say you can't see my grandson until you
treat my mom right then then you're
using your son as a pawn and now now
it's just gonna make a mess
yeah I can I completely understand I
I decided to uh to call in to ask you
for your opinion because I consulted
with other men that I could consider of
uh integrity and high value and it was
kind of a split decision
um one one of the men that I consulted
with they suggested to not get involved
in marriage problems that are you know
that I'm not a part of the marriage and
then another individual that I consulted
with he had said that if you made a
commitment to only allowing certain
types of people in your life
whether they're your parent or not does
not justify or excuse their behavior
and that's where it's been really
conflicting with me because with my
friends or cousins or whoever if you
cheat
uh on your spouse or your girlfriend or
boyfriend whoever may be
there is something inside me that says
well if you're not going to tell them I
am and if I lose your relationship if I
lose a relationship with you because of
it then okay with that
and my dad's kind of been the exception
for so long because he's my dad and it
does it does not feel right anymore it's
never felt right but it just feels like
our relationship is broken and wounded
because of these decisions
and he's actually taken me
with him when I was younger
um
when he was doing when he was cheating
on my mother before and um so that was
honestly
go ahead
that was honestly the hardest thing to
unpack and actually your show actually
helped me unpack that because
um for a long time it was really hard to
accept that
he had did that and then two days later
I had to go see my mom and basically I
saw them down at 13 to lie to her that
you know basically cover up for him you
know yeah I
I'm nervous about you channeling that
inner pain what your dad did to you
sucks man what your dad did to you is is
immoral and is wrong and like you said a
grown-up put a 13 year old in in a very
precarious position and now how old are
you
I'm 28 sir you're 28 man you're still
beating up that 13 year old for not
having more courage you gotta you gotta
lay off that 13 year old man
that's tough
that was Madness
because you know as well as I do
it you can look back now and be like I
should have done this I should have done
this but you're looking back now through
a 28 year old man's body
that 13 year old would have got his head
knocked off
or if he didn't mom might have
and so you gotta you gotta let that 13
year old off the hook because what's
turning what's happening is you're
turning into Batman you're turning into
a vigilante
and you were playing God over other
people's relationships my rule of thumb
is if I've got somebody in my life that
has an ongoing affair with somebody
I am choosing to not be around them
if they're somebody Ops me into this
conversation
let's say
um I'll make up something uh a close
buddy of mine
let's say he's cheating on somebody for
a long long time like he's got a year of
fear going on with somebody at work
and his wife calls me
and said I think something's going on
I know you love my husband I know y'all
are close
but I feel like something's wrong
something's going off the rails what I
would do is I would call my buddy and
say your wife has brought me into this
and she's somebody I care for and be
willing to lay down my life for as well
because she's in our gang you got 48
hours because I'm not going to lie to
your wife
but if she doesn't bring me into that
I'm not going to go around nuking things
because I have this inner 13 year old
that is so pissed at himself for not
defending his mom
over 15 years ago
but I am going to opt out a relationship
with that person I'm not gonna hang out
with that guy because I don't hang out
with guys like that
yeah and you see how you see how in my
voice how simple it is
you know what I mean it's just an it's
just an opt out and if one of my buddies
screwed up and had a one night stand or
found himself like head over heels for
somebody for a month at work I would sit
with him man I'm not gonna abandon you
in that
but also if somebody's having an affair
for over a year they would know they
know me right they're my they're my
friend they know what my opinion is
going to be on there they know I'm not
going to mince words about that and so
that's number one number two is
this is hard for what I'm about to say
okay
but your mom didn't invite you into this
if your mom had called you and said I
need help your dad's out of control
that's one thing
but you were deciding I'm gonna out
adult my mom and she has had her reasons
over the years for staying with a guy
that cheats on her all the time
she's had her reasons for staying with a
scumbag for all these years do you know
what those reasons are
um
she tells me it's because she loves them
and they've been together for so long
that she can't see herself being with
anybody else I hate what I'm about to
tell you
but she gets to make that choice she's
an adult
that's what one of the individuals that
the individual that I talk to about
staying out of it that's what he said
she's a grown-up
your choice is as another grown-up what
are me and my house gonna do
who are we gonna be
and that's a harder conversation it's
actually easier in a way to throw
grenades
because the explosion is over there
somewhere else and you can feel very
self-righteous in doing so because
there's harm being done
but if someone doesn't invite you in
someone doesn't look at you and say help
then it's kind of impaired I mean it's
Madness and then you got to deal with
your own home and that hurts man it's a
bummer
yeah my mom's uh she's coming to me
often you know asking me things you know
asking what I should do or asking me for
a device but she's never she did not
open this particular door I opened it
right
and I don't and now that we're talking
about it
um as much as I want
I feel like you're right I feel like I
was
I was weaponizing the relationship with
my dad and my son because I feel like
that's something he would do
and you see how it happened you see how
it happens without us realizing it
yeah your old man weaponized you against
your mom when he was out carousing
and yeah that's for sure in a very
similar context
you have taken your son and put him
right in the same line it's just a
different line
and your dad I promise you
has some moral reason he has convinced
himself however delusional and deranged
it is he's convinced himself well she
never does this and she's always doing
this and so I need to I work hard I need
a little you know a little fun on the
side every once in a while he's got a
reason
and then strangely and weirdly
and this is how family trauma just rolls
downhill without us even realizing it
yeah and that's what I'm trying that's
what I'm trying to stop I'm trying to
I've already committed that and I I
forgive my dad for what he's done like I
don't beat him up over I don't bring it
up I don't ask him for an apology
because the thing is it's like
um
I I've heard you know things they said
like there's nothing that can really be
done about the past like apology is not
going to help and it's well apology
would go a long way if your old man
collagen said I was wrong I was wrong
I'm sorry that would be that'd be huge
and he meant like make no mistake that
that would be therapeutic in a way that
would be hard to describe but I want you
to pay very close attention to the world
you've created
can I be super direct with you is that
cool
yeah yeah
so you have in in protecting the tiny
cocoon that is your wife and you have
one kid or two kids how many kids you
got
um well I'm I'm not married but um okay
I I I have one son he's he's four years
old okay so you got you and your son
it's you against the world right and
you've decided I am not gonna be a guy
that cheats I'm not I'm not gonna be a
guy that lies I'm not
but I am going to tell anytime I see it
anywhere around me I'm gonna pick up the
phone I'm gonna pick up my social media
I'm gonna tell their spouse I'm gonna
tell their girlfriend I'm going to tell
everybody
in a weird way you've repeated your
dad's insistence on blowing up families
you've just decided to do it to other
people instead of your own
but the impulse is the exact same
and so healing looks like a true
forgiveness and you haven't forgiven
your old man because that 13 year old is
still playing Batman out there
number one you gotta let your old man go
and that doesn't mean that doesn't mean
washing your hands of it he was terrible
to you and I don't like talking about
other people's parents but your dad was
rough on you man
put you through the worst
and the second thing is
instead of being somebody who blows up
other people's marriages for the sake of
for value and for right I'm gonna be a
guy that will do whatever it takes for
people I know and love to help them keep
things together
because I'm a unifier not a blower upper
you see the difference there
I do and it's kind of there's there's
one thing where you said where it's kind
of conflicting so I'm hoping you can
kind of help me at library a little bit
you got it about about blowing up the
other family or other marriages
like to me it feels like if they didn't
make those decisions that it's not me
blowing it up and stem blowing it up
they are but you don't get a vote
yeah
it's almost as though you are running
around looking for places to insert
righteousness into it
and they didn't ask you for that
that makes you vigilante
the greatest gift you can give is to be
an epicenter of such outrageous insane
piece
that when not if but when things get off
the rails in your friend's marriages
when things get off the rails in your
friends lives
they go to one person that instantly
something goes sideways like I gotta
call Eric
I'm over my head I'm about to respond to
this text I'm about to DM this I gotta
call Eric
and if they create worlds where don't
tell Eric don't tell Eric hey don't
invite Eric because Eric's gonna be on
radar alert looking for who's screwing
up per his judgment
that's not the influence that's the
influential man has
but an influence of now everybody knows
where Eric stands
and everybody knows that Eric loves his
son like we've never seen a father love
a son ever
that guy's always hugging that kid that
guy's always kissing that kid that guy's
always looking him in the eyes and
saying thank God Almighty that I get to
be your dad
never see anything like it
and then when their marriages get in
trouble
they holler at you
you see the difference man
yeah
it's a total shift
uh so I kind of I have a question about
that like
because during this conversation it's
kind of felt like a big
it feels like a big
you know suitcase of angers and taken
off my shoulders
but at the same time it's like
I just really want to treat my mom a lot
better and I'm just not sure I'm not
sure how to do it if it's in my place to
do it so now you're talking
so you're a kind of guy that honors his
mom beyond what even makes sense
you're not a guy that tries to fix her
marriage because she's a grown woman she
can do whatever she wants
but you're a son do y'all live in the
same town
I'm sorry you all live in the same town
oh yes okay you are a son this is an
identity I'm a son who takes my mom on a
breakfast date
with me and her grandson once a week we
never miss
I'm a guy who once a week on Friday
evenings me and my four-year-old son we
make a card out of construction paper
and glue and whatever wood nails we make
Grandma one present a week
52 weeks 52 presents a year
and now you're not a your identity isn't
I'm not I'm a guy that makes sure every
marriage is perfect even though you got
a kid and you're not married right I'm
gonna make I'm sure every that's not my
identity my identity is I'm gonna be s
I'm gonna honor my mom
to the point where she has to look in
the mirror and say oh my goodness this
is what love looks like
I am worth more than this
and that's what you can control the
relationship from your side to your mom
you can control your identity you see
the difference there man
yeah I I definitely do it's
my mom and I we've had a we've had a
rocky relationship especially when I was
a teenager and of course you know
classic guys when you're 18 19 you think
you know everything yes you get older
honestly the best thing for her and I
ever was when I moved out of state and
then I moved back a few years later her
and I we grew a lot closer every time
there's a great uh I think it's a Mark
Twain quote which is when I was 14 my
dad was the stupidest man on the planet
I'm butchering the quote but when I was
14 my dad was the dumbest man in the in
in on the planet and then when I came
back home at the age of 21 I was stunned
at how much my dad had learned in seven
years all right
you got some sense and got some wisdom
and I got I got some bad news for you
the bad news is
as knuckleheaded as you were at 18 and
19 you know you're 28 and you can see
that with such wisdom and Clarity my
promise is that doubles when you're 38
looking back at 28 year old self
the things you think are right and
perfect and this is the way
at 28 I promise when you turn 40 you're
like oh man I was way off way off
and I want to take you mentioned that
that suitcase of anger
when you were at a party and you were
hyper vigilantly does that everybody say
that scanning the room to make sure
everybody's doing right
you know who that's that that pains and
hurts you it's exhausting
all the energy you spent trying to fix
your parents marriage that they didn't
ask you to fix all the energy you spent
being pissed off at your dad for all
these years that just weighs down you it
doesn't change their behavior doesn't
fix their marriage it just weighs down
you and you got a four-year-old little
boy that's looking next at looking up at
you at all times absorbing you
and his one question is why is Dad so
angry all the time
why is Dad so angry it must be me I'm
gonna try to fix it
I need him to see me
because if he can just see me he won't
be so angry and that's how this thing
goes in a cycle in a cycle and a cycle
and a cycle
and I have no doubt in my mind Eric
you're gonna be the guy that breaks that
cycle for your family
you're gonna break it stops with me
which means I don't carry anger anymore
except for one or two or three very big
Hills that I'm gonna die on I'll die on
those every time no question about it
but when it comes to the guy who was
just driving down the road when I was
getting here this morning with a
ponytail and his and he's got he's got a
license plates that are vanity plates
that said Hollywood
and he cut me off
my first impulse just started laughing
a few years ago my first impulse would
have been I'm gonna smash the back of
your car and create a huge pile up I'll
show you
and of course I was just talking crap
and I wouldn't do any of those things
and by the time I got to work I would be
real close to a stroke slash heart
attack slash diarrhea all three of them
my body just be like we're just gonna
shut everything down so all I have to
say is this
stop torturing my friend Eric
my friend Eric has is an amazing guy
he's done some amazing things and he's
making some extraordinary changes
stop carrying the anger
stop hearing the anger
be very intentional I want you to write
down your new identities I'm a guy
who is about keeping marriages together
not making sure
that they're all right
I'm a guy who will honor his mom I'm a
guy who will create a peaceful
non-anxious home for my son
now you're talking
family tree changing ways of being
and on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of own your past change your future
I want you to read that brother and that
will walk you through all that crap
you've been through and then give you a
path out my man thank you so much for
the call